i think i was
planning or maybe even hoping in some
ways to find that
these these kind of spirit of the moment
movements that that took off
and really disrupted the status quo
in ways that had you know not previously
been imagined that they were
going to be actually more important
than they ended up being right and i
think like i said one thing that i
realized is that
it wasn't that romantic moment of
stepping out right it wasn't the moment
of taking to the streets that actually
made
the difference in terms of how that
particular
political situation transpired or
unfolded it was the
kind of larger context those bigger
struggles that that you know initial
spark was really only a part of
so i think that that's kind of what
maybe the biggest lesson i learned from
it right is that i
i think maybe i also bought into some of
the romanticism of
pure politics of that that moment of
interruption or disruption which is
attractive right because it is
there's something to it about people
working together
outside of their normal spaces as equals
trying to reimagine something different
but yeah as i found out i think that was
only a starting place for all of these
[Music]
movements
[Music]
uh hello plastic pills listeners as some
of you may know i've been working on my
phd dissertation on democratic theory
one of my
main focuses is radical democratic
theory and in the process of doing
that research uh for the dissertation i
came across an intriguing book called
radical democracy in its limits limits
by
david is it mata jacovich is that right
there you go
awesome i got it the first time i meant
to ask you before we started recording
but like whatever
uh and uh he's an instructor at simon
fraser university
uh david and i have been corresponding
on and off for maybe like a couple years
and i figured it was finally time to
have him on the podcast especially given
many of our patrons
are interested in anarchism and also
like radical politics in general
so yeah david matajosevich welcome to
the pill pod yeah thanks so much for
having me great to
be on awesome so um i want to start
by just kind of i think what makes your
book interesting and unique
is that you uh combine theoretical
engagement with thinkers like
ernesto leclaire chantelmuff roncier and
a bunch of others with kind of like an
empirical analysis of uh democratic
social movements
and if i'm not mistaken uh you're
primarily trained as a political
scientist as a theorist
is that right that's right so primarily
trained as a theorist but also
i'm kind of splitting my time with
comparative um
so kind of in in both in both realms and
i guess that's
um the book i guess kind of speaks to
that in some ways uh trying to really
showcase the the best of both worlds i
guess
yeah totally and did you so what what
got you originally interested in that
topic kind of like was it during your
phd or were you always interested in
radical democracy or radical politics
like what was that story
like kind of the inception of the book
yeah right so i mean i
i've always been very interested in in
protest politics
particularly um and social movements
generally speaking
and that's that's something that i was
very interested in not just kind of
exploring in
an academic way but with something that
just really intrigued me and
sometimes i was kind of active in um
and in some form at universities i was
at as well
um so it was also something that that i
lived in a way um
and i became quite intrigued with this
idea of radical democracy because i
think it really spoke to
a lot of the global movements and global
protests
that have been taking off um during the
period of
occupy wall street and also the arab
spring and subsequently i mean we've had
probably a decade or so of an almost
unprecedented level
of protest globally um perhaps
some people are saying more now than
even in what was considered kind of the
heyday in the 1960s and 70s
that we've kind of returned to this
level and radical democratic theory
i felt really spoke to some of the
normative underpinnings of these
movements
um but with that said and one thing that
i do
touch on in the book is having taken a
look at so many examples of these
movements being shut down
or not not succeeding in any type of
political or social transformation
this really led me to to question kind
of the validity
of the theory as a type of model
that could be used as a type of
political prescription and hence
um why i decided to approach that in my
dissertation which became the book
just quickly though for our viewers who
don't know can you define
agonistic democracy a little bit and one
of the reasons i bring up this question
is
uh i can't think of anyone who would
agree that there is a settled definition
uh on it you know mccloud has one
interpretation ron sierra have another
uh sean tomliff actually intriguingly
enough is uh identifies as a liberal
socialist so has a very different kind
of perception of it
so what would your vision of agonistic
democracy be yeah i think it's a good
it's a good question matt um it's it's a
hard one because i think you're right
the definition is not
quite settled um and even in the
introduction to the book
it was quite a challenge for me to
really try to pin down what do all of
these thinkers have in common because
they do have a number of things in
common
um which is i mean a couple of those
things we could say are first of all
kind of a commitment to we can say maybe
extra institutional forms of politics
and a type of politics that imagines
people
engaging in a way that goes beyond the
normal way that they're identified
the normal kind of bounds and structures
through which they they usually
participate in the normal channels
through which they participate
um so there's that emphasis which they
hold in common um now the agonistic part
uh this is a question i get all of the
time for those that don't do
uh democratic theory specifically well
what what in the world is agonism
what is this um and we can see it as
uh kind of this in between space between
consensus and antagonism
it's a commitment to a type of
pluralistic politics where you will have
fierce disagreement fierce engagement of
different political views
but one that doesn't reach the level of
political violence or coercion um so in
some ways it's
it's a type of radical pluralism and the
understanding that
a few extra institutional politics um
done in this type of pluralist way
that spaces can be opened up for
reimagining the world for alternatives
being pushed forward
for for policy changes to be enacted and
sometimes even for larger
transformations to occur
um yeah so in setting up the main
argument of the book
um you argue that like certain
conditions need to be in place for
agonistic democracy to be
sustainable and like maybe this is gonna
require like a long explanation but i
don't know if there if there's some way
you could kind of give us a
a bit of a of an idea of like what you
see as these kinds of
um and that's and just like give the
audience an idea right like you have a
number of case studies in the book where
you talk about like real examples of
like social movements and
and you you identify like moments in
those movements that could qualify as
like an open space a space in between
like a space of agonism right and
but you also set the book up and the
argument um very well i think to talk
about how there's
these conditions i think there were four
so if you could talk about some of those
i think that'd be that'd be great
yeah right so i think i mean one thing
that i realized
um going through the research and
putting the
brain argument together after doing the
case studies is that
the conditions under which kind of the
conditions on which agonism
can be maintained are quite quite
limited
um because ultimately they do depend
very much
on the benevolence of the ruling
authorities or the dominant social force
and this perhaps doesn't come as too
much of a surprise
when you take a look at certain case
studies that are in the book and then
also cases around the world
one kind of bug bear i guess i had with
a lot of
radical democratic thought is despite
its supposed radicalism
um the theorists all of the theories
that are identified like like rancier or
like mccloud
maybe less so but many of their examples
are coming out of
the liberal democratic world they're
coming out of political systems where
you actually have some um
some standard um or perhaps we can even
say
a very kind of well-oiled machine of
democratic mechanisms where spaces exist
um you have constitutional rights you
have all of these and
they don't discuss all of this very much
because that wouldn't appeal to their
radicalism in a lot of ways
um but when looking at other cases in
cases where
you you don't have clear liberal
democratic politics and you you don't
have
kind of constitutional guarantees on
certain spaces
um antagonism is often the order of the
day particularly when it comes to social
movements
and they they become repressed
quite quickly or they become co-opted
quite easily and really limit
the power that this type of politics can
can have one of the main conditions that
uh i think was established after i went
through this this book is that it's it's
really
aside from the benevolence of the
dominant force it's really up to
the the protest group or the movement
itself to try to win itself space
um in ways that will actually allow it
to uh to open up the possibilities of
greater change
and this can be through of course
building alliances
through taking over particular social
political spaces
that are important to the ruling power
and this is i think incredibly important
in
authoritarian systems and in some of the
cases show that
so fundamentally that i think
if i if i can answer it in a short way
one of the main conditions
um is that the movement has to have a
capacity
for for challenging the dominant order
if it doesn't simply want to rely on its
benevolence which will run out quite
fast if those demands are indeed
radical um and that's i think that's
something that maybe is not
discussed as thoroughly as it could be
within the theoretical body of work
itself
in in terms of alliance building in
terms of the actual strategies of
movement building and alliance building
and
um and democratic resistance if you will
i
had a follow-up question actually um on
the subject matter of social cohesion uh
so
one of the things that's interesting
about the kind of radical democratic
movement
is that it situates itself very far on
the opposite end of the spectrum from
something like social conservatism right
social conservatism tends to advocate
for a very thick
kind of glue that binds us together
whether it be traditionalism
support for markets uh religion you know
there are various different clues that
they kind of put forward right
then you move forward to something like
the rawlsian liberal
pluralist tradition which says we can't
have less social cohesion than that
we just all need to subject ourselves to
an overlapping consensus
that we might not necessarily agree with
initially but gradually over time when
we see that institutionally
this works uh we'll come to respect the
institutions of liberal democracy
and you know the kind of rights that
flow from that and then the radical
democrats are at the other end and i
think he put this very very well
where they say we don't really need any
social glue whatsoever
uh everyone should be able to exist in
their particularity permanently
without institutions doing anything to
try to efface that
but then we'll dialogue with one another
in this kind of agonistic way
and this is the best kind of political
form that's possible because it's the
most free political form
can you tell me a little bit about like
what the normative argument for that
kind of radical pluralism is
because looking at the work of somebody
like ron sharer or looking at the work
of uh mcleod
moof i'm sympathetic to the democratic
feature of their argument
but i'm not entirely sure why it's such
a good thing
uh for people just be able to express
their identity without any real
recognition
that it might be important to develop a
kind of consensus on issues with the
other
yeah okay i mean i think it's it's an
excellent question um
and to be frank man i think it's it's a
problem that i also share
um with with those thinkers and with
radical democratic thought
um going i guess to the first part of
your
your statement and question uh with
regard to this necessity of social glu
um one thing that comes becomes quite
apparent in the case study is that
uh often in situations where you did
have something
or do have something that very much
embodies radical democracy and in
practice
it's a type of permanent politics
society becomes ultimately political um
so i'm thinking in my book i talk about
the case of thailand in in the last 10
or 15 years where
you've had kind of constant street
politics
constant occupations constant um
attempts at a government overthrow coup
d'etats all of this right
and when it comes to that type of thing
it does make you wonder and it's
something that i
refer to in the book that um we can make
an argument that
political engagement in itself can be a
positive thing
it can be an end in itself however
maybe one way to say is that it can't be
the only end of politics
there does need to be some type of
project and that project requires
some degree of cohesion as you put it at
least amongst
some members of the society in order for
it to
to operate right in order for it to work
in order for um some form of justice
to actually become real um otherwise it
it does just become this kind of
permanent type of politics right
um so that that's my own criticism of it
in terms of where i think they see it
coming from
i think they're all of those thinkers
are really coming from a type of
post-foundationalism where they do not
see
any particular justification
or any permanent justification for a
certain type of political
order or form of rule right so what they
would say is that
i mean maybe to put it kind of crudely
right to the rosians out there
uh to the harbour mostly out there they
might say that okay
well there are lots of folks that have
doubts about rawls and hovermoss
right and how they might structure kind
of a liberal institutionalist order
as long as there are people that have
doubts um and legitimate doubts and can
make good arguments about why those
folks are wrong
we should always leave politics open to
plurality
because there are so many different
types of possibilities that we can
envision so that that's something that i
can sympathize with
in terms of the dangers of putting
forward um kind of a modest
type of politics um however i
i do think that going on that other end
like you said at other end of the
spectrum where no social glue is needed
does lead to this type of
kind of purist permanent politics that
that isn't transformative and then might
not even lead to a type of justice in
the end right
so no i absolutely agree with you and
this is why i wanted
a kind of follow-up question uh which is
you know i'm a liberal democratic
socialist right uh i believe that
we should be politicizing everything
right uh particularly adopting a
critical mentality towards institutions
that are held to be sacrosanct right but
i do appreciate the fact that for many
people
uh being liberated from the necessity of
politics is
part of the reason why they become
radicals in the first place right they
don't necessarily want to have to
sit there and constantly fight for their
rights or fight for recognition their
identity they want to engage in other
kinds of creative projects of
self-development or whatever it happens
to be
and i've never really seen radical
democracy as offering anything to these
people
precisely because it's supposed to be so
permanently political
right do you think that would be a
legitimate criticism and can you see
examples of that in some of the case
studies that you looked at
i mean that's that's a really
interesting question i think
you know what matt i i have a feeling
that you might have um revealed one of
my own political biases right
because i think um even though i have my
doubts about this idea of permanent
politics
and permanent political engagement
perhaps myself i i do
have uh an inclination to to see
political engagement
as a type of higher order good oh
absolutely i think we all do right
or at least maybe those of us that are
you know are talking about this on on
podcasts and
the folks who you guys talk to um kind
of weekend and week out so
um but for for those folks that want to
engage in a different way
like let's say you're talking about like
in an artistic way um
or in a way that is not not about um
confronting power or achieving power
right
um i think some of the thinkers do offer
something i mean i think the work of
jacqueline sierra and his his work on
aesthetics
for example is is a type of of politics
that that does offer something in terms
of uh
a destructive type of politics right um
or a politics of shattering expectations
um or
or even bonnie hanik's work in terms of
the development of the new
right and that politics is about new
um innovative ideas and breaking out of
old models and boxes right
so i think there's something there um
and that is offered
but what's interesting about that when
it comes to politics one of the problems
i
i see with that kind of model being
applied and then i put this
i state this in the book in the
introduction
and in other parts as well um their type
of politics i feel
tends to be a little bit too focused on
disruption
and not enough on construction uh
particularly in terms of constructing
kind of a common world or a common
transformative project right
so in some ways you know while they they
might focus on kind of this pure
politics in a lot of ways in other ways
um they're not they're not so focused on
building
and hence i think they leave a lot of
people out who
are are less interested in
deconstructing kind of the world we have
right now
right and who might be more interested
in in building something
different or new um now those two things
go together but i think the emphasis in
their work
tends to be on the former rather than
the latter which is a
critique i have as well absolutely yeah
so i was interested in this relates to
some of the questions i'm exploring in
my own work you know i think
one of the things that stands out to me
about like this space
of agonism i guess is like it seems like
maybe there's some kind of an account
of civic virtue implied that it's like
you know it's like you need to adopt in
this kind of
i think it's like a not so easy attitude
to maintain
right like this this agonist like i know
william connolly talks about agonistic
respect and and i forgot critical
responsiveness right like these are
these are two two attitudes that he
thinks are like necessary for having a
kind of like democratic pluralist
politics and
like as you were discussing before you
know this drive to to
have this kind of oppositional politics
but it like
all of the thinkers seem to some extent
want to somehow
hold back the descriptive potential of
that and it seems to me
that the way that they argue for that is
that oh people will adopt this attitude
which i think could be called like a
kind of civic virtue and i just wonder
if you
like if you agree or if you could talk
about like that in general
it's a really interesting point roncir
doesn't get into it as much but there
are hints in the work
that there still needs to be this
understanding of mutual respect
right there's this idea of kind of
respecting the equal or the other as an
equal
right um so it does get into this this
realm and i agree
um and what for me the problem that i
have
with that and then this is also one of
the reasons that i did want to explore
the case studies is because i
um i found that to be quite hard to
swallow
that it simply requires kind of the
adoption of
attitudes of virtue or tolerance
um and one thing that comes out in
in the book at least that i try to make
clear is that it's it's not so much
a matter of disrespect towards another
or or even
um disrespect towards another's
political
position or existence right it's it's
just the idea that
your own fundamental political position
is fundamental to you
and to your group for a reason and that
there are going to be certain things
about your position that
are uncompromisable and when it comes
down to a particular conflict whereby
compromises cannot be made and pluralism
cannot exist then those virtues
can be tossed aside pretty quickly and
they are tossed aside pretty quickly and
then we've seen that and
i think in recent times in the last five
years or so which is
kind of after i finished up writing the
dissertation
um we've seen how this has happened
right we've seen how actual
um maybe a return to the political if
you will
you know uh some some serious antagonism
between different political positions in
the west but also around the world
has led to these virtues
being totally cast aside um and for
myself the way i see it
i don't see that as um a matter of
these virtues not having been promoted
or the fact that people like william
connolly haven't had enough of a voice
i think it has something to do with the
nature of the contest itself
and the nature of the struggle between
these contesting
ideas themselves yeah i think that's
that's good and i think we're probably
on pretty similar pages there i think uh
you know it does raise just the question
of stability right like how because i
think like these attitudes
like it just seems really hard to rely
on them as you were saying right like
people can set them aside so quickly
right
and and of course like because they have
these kind of anti-foundationalist
sympathies that almost prevents them
from being able to talk about
what those things mean in like a thick
manner because like if you start talking
too much
about the required attitudes all of a
sudden you're becoming a foundationalist
right because if you're talking about
like what the right attitude so they
just kind of have to vaguely like you
like your right to say rancier you know
appeals a little bit to equality but
then you know connolly does a little bit
more but um
yeah that always strikes me as uh kind
of a paradox in in anti-foundationalist
political theory that it's like
in avoiding it they miss they like they
they don't let themselves talk about
something that seems important but then
they kind of talk about it just
unsatisfactorily yeah
you're very right and i think that might
be um it might be very much
the fact that they by talking about it
more they would fall into the trap of
undermining
a lot of their own work um it goes back
to matt's point about this idea of the
glue
so in in some ways they're putting
forward this idea of
these virtues of agonistic respect
responsive critical responsiveness
um an appeal to respecting the other as
an equal uh
as a type of this clue but it's when it
comes down to actual
political contests when it it becomes a
matter of
to put it crudely who wins um who who
actually achieves political power who
gets the policy written
who is in and who is out when we live in
societies whereby a lot of times those
types of decisions have to be made and
we can't have full pluralism
then how how does that how does that
conundrum get resolved and i think
that's not something that's addressed in
their work
very well one of the odd things about
the radical democratic movement
is that there's a kind of normative
implication
that's latent within their arguments
right which is that
our absolute respect for difference uh
is what we should do
right respect for the other uh in their
otherness uh and
i never really think that's particularly
well argued for by
these kind of radical democrats even if
i sympathize with the position right
but one of the things that i think is
problematic with this argument for
absolute respect for difference is it
doesn't really account
for what i see to be the primary virtue
of democracy actually
which is this idea as you put it very
artfully of constructing a world
together
right and i think that this is where a
genuine democratic politics differs from
either a liberal politics or
so-called radical democrats because the
kind of liberal politics will say that
this is the kind of standard set of
liberal rights that you get you don't
have to engage in politics at all
or engage in any kind of socially free
activity uh just live your private life
that's fine
whereas these radical democrats say we
need to have absolute respect for the
other in their particularity
and even understanding that we might
never be able to come to terms with one
another
um i think you know this idea of
constructing a shared world together as
a democratic activity
that a rent puts forward amongst others
i should say like it's a lot more
inspiring and a lot more
true to the spirit of democracy going
back to ancient athens and i was
wondering if you think that that's
true yeah um i i think
i you and i are on um a very similar
type of
uh maybe if not exactly the same page um
we're on
you know the we're in the same chapter
matt
not too far off on that um i think
that's i think that's right
um even though like i said earlier i do
think this idea of
breaking down barriers of taking people
out of boxes
um kind of a more deconstructive
politics is important
right because it that's that's necessary
to
um to question the world as it is now
right and to reimagine it as something
that could be different or better
um but it's only the first step right
um and in a lot of ways the radical
democrats in
in kind of their their appeal to
be kind the recognition of difference as
as kind of the ultimate end
um and then depending on which thinker
you're looking at i think they take that
um they take that in different ways and
then connolly definitely takes that the
furthest and some of the others like
move takes it
less less for um
as as a result of her own political
commitments i think but
um i agree that in the body of work
they they do not uh focus on on the act
of building or constructing um
or even even the idea of of dialogue
right i mean right there's there's a lot
of um
not not that i'm um that i'm the biggest
fan of deliberative democracy
i'm sure that's something talked about
with other folks on your show
but i think there is something to this
idea of people coming together and
actually
hashing out a plan for for living
together in a just
way um and unfortunately with the
radical democrats i think
once that is done it's kind of seen as
creating
otherness what's creating exclusions um
it's the process of constructing is
automatically
othering right and that's kind of the
first thing
they turn to and if i go back to hanukk
i think there's one part
of her work i think it might be in
emergency politics um
where she says something to the effect
of you know the second after the
constitution is written
the people become um they're no longer
the authors of it
they kind of become subjected to it and
hence it should be open to rewriting
um and it's it's this kind of spirit
which
um as much as i think that's that's
necessary to always
keep politics open to to keep
possibilities open
taking that too far leads to the leads
to a situation whereby
people can never really engage in
meaningful construction together
um and it's interesting because hanug is
kind of a neo-orrentian and she goes
very much a rent
very much against the rent in that way
right where
um she moves away from that that kind of
aurentian understanding of um
building building a world together um
through through dialogue
right or through great acts and deeds as
she might put it no i absolutely agree
with you but
one of the things that i always try to
contest is this idea that
um you can't find cooperative forms of
radicalism
uh and a book that i really like is jake
owens why not socialism right where
the metaphor he uses for a society of
equals with
where people treat each other with
respect and engage in democratic
processes
is actually a camping trip right and he
says look you know
if you have to cooperate together and
reach a consensus on
what kind of jobs you're going to be
doing on a camping trip
yes that does involve a certain kind of
infringement of your freedom since you
might want to cook rather than canoe or
whatever it happens to be
but most of us will understand that if
this is done in a non-authoritarian way
it's not only necessary for sociality
but it's actually good for sociality
right uh it leads us to have a feeling
of mutual warmth and affection for one
another
it helps us build a better trip you know
uh over time
and that's the kind of metaphor that i
think is radical but also very inspiring
in a way that the radical democrats
sometimes earn
just to me at least anyway victor i know
you had a question so
you know i i also i i'm cognizant too
that like you know it's interesting a
lot of our listeners and especially
patrons you know they have i think i
mentioned the being they have like some
anarchist
sympathies and like they're probably
gonna give us [ __ ] later on because like
you know matt they always call matt and
either like oh there's those libs
because like the other two guys on the
podcast are like a bit more
post-structuralist and matt and i are
like you know
liberal socialists and sympathetic to
that stuff so like i you know
so i do want to say like at least that i
do find you know radical politics to be
like important and necessary and
you know i'm sympathetic also but i
think you know what's that what's that
issue is how sustainable or
is it as like a you know a serious plan
forward um
i don't know i just felt i felt the need
to like to give that little caveat
but i did want to talk a little bit more
about like the the empirical
um kind of investigation that you have
in the book and
you know and one of the things that i
think sometimes disappoints me about
like a lot of rut like people who
self-describe as radical leftists
especially like online you know
is like i feel like they don't really
understand like power dynamics
especially related to institutions and
and other kinds of like political
factors and i'm curious if you could
talk about like in some of your
empirical case studies
um may be like one of the ones that you
found most revealing
on on how they shed light on how the
necessary dynamics for agonistic
democracy
um to occur and how they interact with
like power dynamics and what sort of
like destabilizes that
that agonistic space as it relates to
kind of like the
the more like political conditions that
i think
you know political scientists tend to
investigate those things much more
than theorists do and i think it's that
can be a mistake if if theorist is
really interested in radical politics
and that's what i think your book
frankly brings to the table so maybe you
could talk about that a little bit
to perhaps um start from a really
crude starting place um in some of the
cases that i explored
uh politics is really nasty business um
it's it's it's something that it's
it's not a picnic and it's not um and
sorry to use your own analogy against
you here maddie i'm not doing it on
purpose but it's not a camping
trip um it's it's a fight it's a
struggle
um it's it's a it's a matter
of um facing the possibility of a
serious defeat defeat
that that could mean um the loss of
one's livelihood or life
uh in some circumstances and i think you
know the most revealing thing and
this is something i go back to in terms
of you know trying not to just look at
cases and liberal democracies right i
think a lot of discussion about
radical movements um
particularly that inform radical theory
often come out of the west and they
often come out of cases like
like occupy um or you know may 68 which
i covered in the book and then i did
that as kind of a
a case study to really just shed light
on it because it's often heralded
as this really anti-institutional
movement
right um and i i wanted to do that
to to just shed light on the fact that
well you know
the fact is that some of the most
radical currents
within let's say may 68 um
were probably the least successful in
terms of
pushing a type of transformation um it
was in fact
those that that tried to engage um
with political power at the level of the
unions at the level of the parties
at the level of the everyday person on
the street and trying to win them over
that that resulted in the potential for
at first
possibly revolutionary change which
didn't happen but but later some
concessions that were formed
um and kind of the so-called student
ghetto
right around the sorbonne in may 68
which is always romanticized
in fact really only operated as long as
it did because it had the support of
this larger movement around it
if it had not done so or if there had
not been this support around it
through you know workers and others that
had joined in this mass movement
it would have either stayed very small
and have just been tolerated and would
not have been remembered
or it would have been crushed quite
quickly
because the type of demands and type of
interruptions they were posing to
ordinary life so to speak were quite
stark um
and it it would have again led to um
well it did lead to violent repression
anyway but perhaps even more so
um so that that was kind of one one case
that really revealed that to me
right that because you know so much
provided radical democratic thought
is often based on some of these more
romantic moments of pure politics
um but behind the scenes what's actually
sustained them um what's actually
allowed them
to develop that type of romance is
everything else that was going on and
that happened to be the engagement with
power
um and that that type of capital p
politics that was taking place right
i guess is the second thing you know
taking a look at the southeast asian
cases so
just to talk a little bit more about my
own my own background my work
i'm really interested in the politics of
southeast asia when i do my comparative
work
i i tend to focus on cases
from thailand or malaysia or singapore
it's a place where i've spent some time
and the thing that's always very
revealing about that region is that
again
these the regimes
in in these countries um are are not
liberal democracies
and they they do not allow for these
particular spaces so
um radical politics really means radical
politics it really means risking
everything
to take part in it um and and you see
that
um when these movements engage so when
it when it comes
to uh the the foundations for agonism
what allowed for agonism the one thing
that's really revealing
in those cases is that in in situations
where
um you have an authoritarian state and
that authoritarian state has quite a bit
of legitimacy
uh ultimately um a type of
destructive politics that remains at
that level
um is is not able to
transform anything and not only that
it can't even allow for the type of um
more kind of individualist or
a political type of um
transformation that could be possible so
i'm thinking about
kind of uh i hate to use this word but
like lifestyle anarchism
right i mean like something like
lifestyle anarchism where you kind of
separate yourself from the authorities
separate yourself from the state you
don't engage in politics
you kind of just live your own life and
do what you want in a place like
thailand or a place like singapore
that's not even possible because you
don't have liberal democracy
um and sometimes you know in the west
uh we kind of take those liberal
democratic foundations for granted
and think that we we can kind of live
that way and be that way and not engage
um and just subtract ourselves or
separate ourselves from those struggles
and just
do it ourselves but what those cases
really reveal
is that it's not possible actually
engaging
in transformation so that people can
engage in a more democratic way or even
in a more liberal
individualist way as maybe matt was
alluding to before
um requires the transformation of
society it required
requires actual real political
engagement again at that capital p level
so this kind of goes back to my earlier
point about why i think
the need for larger movements
that engage with with more people um
in movement building alliance building
um is necessary to even
allow for the type of um
liberal type of existence
that maybe we take for granted in uh
some western countries
yeah you you touched on so many things
that i that i agree with
um you know i think the point that you
make is so important and actually
i think i was talking to like one of our
listeners the other day about like
anarchist communes you know and there
and i was like i think touching on i
think the point you make is so important
that like
the reliance on background conditions
right of like liberal democracy for
certain kinds of political association
to be possible
is something that's often missed and you
know i think the romanticism
just does get it does kind of like you
know interfere with uh with i guess
ability to see
to see like those conditions so yeah
it's it's really so interesting but um
matt i think you had something next if
you want go ahead absolutely i just want
to say that i completely agree
uh with what you said and just speaking
from my own experience
my wife is mexican and i lived in mexico
for two or three years uh and it really
compelled me to re-evaluate some of the
critical opinions i had about things
like
the rule of law or trust and um
government institutions right
because it was a very different cultural
environment there where in many parts of
the country
there really was very very minimal rule
of law and no one had
any trust in institutions and things
often didn't work very well
and people complained about it
consistently and how they wanted to
shift things
in a more developed direction right but
it's hard to do because of course if you
don't trust institutions and then
institutions try to enact change
right the people tend to be resistant of
that or at the very least they tend to
be skeptical that it's going to lead to
any kind of meaningful benefit
to them uh so one of the kind of jobs
that someone like amlo for instance
uh assumed was trying to convince the
people that when he said he was going to
change the mexican state and reduce
corruption he really was going to do
that
right and of course it's still an
ongoing project um but the question that
i had for you
is i think you very rightly point out
that a lot
of proponents of radical democracy do
indeed kind of
fixate too much on western social
conditions and kind of rely on
background assumptions about
the stability of the state this ability
of law respect for basic rights
while arguing for their kinds of
positions but why did you choose to
focus on
southeast asia in particular countries
like malaysia singapore
and thailand and what kind of lessons do
you think people living in western
countries can learn
from these case studies yeah those
those are two really good questions um i
hope
if i end up kind of going on a tangent
just just nod your head or something
um our show is all about tangents
believe me so yeah no it's all good it's
all good feel free honestly indulge
totally
um i mean there are a couple i guess a
couple of responses
um one of the reasons why i focused on
southeast asia and maybe it's very much
like you were just suggesting that with
your own experience with mexico
it's a place where i spent time
and it really changed a lot of my
assumptions about
how politics operates and what is
politically possible and
how how reimagining society
might need to take a different type of
route
in order to get there because i think a
lot of my own i mean i i was
i grew up in canada um i was very much
trained not just in kind of western
political theory but but also western
political science and
very much accustomed to certain norms
and conditions
that exist here right um and
spending time in southeast asia
particularly thailand and singapore
where i spent the most time
just just was a kind of a real world
lesson about
what's really possible under not just
authoritarian conditions
um not just when you have an
authoritarian regime but also when you
have an authoritarian political culture
in a lot of ways or where the acceptance
of non-liberal ways of going about
things is a lot more predominant than it
is in the west
um so not only are you kind of fighting
against the state
and traditional elites and all of that
you're also
struggling against a large segment of
society even for things like basic
rights
right and so folks that are democrats or
folks that are socialists
for example right they've got quite the
struggle because
they're really fighting it on multiple
fronts um
and i think my own experience in
thailand um i i was traveling in
thailand in 2008
um and that was that was actually a
period i ended up covering in the book
um there was an occupation of the major
airports in the country and i got i was
stuck
i was stuck in thailand for a little
while because of that um
and i just at that at that point um i
had not really been in thailand
to do research or conduct really any
study on it politically
um i was there for some other reasons um
traveling around and um also doing a bit
of teacher training
but that that moment um where
you know i i saw those kind of mass
occupations
and what it eventually led to as i kept
following it which was
an eventual coup d'etat some years on
uh just really really made me think
about
what the limitations are to the type of
politics that i had even been a
proponent of back home
right um and certain strategies that
i've been a proponent of back home so it
made me reevaluate it maybe
very much like you know you re-evaluated
some of your own ideas
not in mexico um so that it was
partially personal
experience and partially some of those
lessons that i got up
the other thing to indulge a little bit
the other thing too is i think um
i maybe your listeners are gonna think
you've done this on purpose but i think
i also consider myself a type of uh
liberal democratic socialist
i think i i believe the institutions of
liberal democracy are
really quite important so
and i think that that comes from my
experiences in those places because
uh bringing about a type of economic
transformation
where you have a higher degree of
economic justice
actually requires fundamental civil and
political rights
being institutionalized to even get
there
because otherwise what you see and i
think this is something that comes out
in the book
is you you end up having these uh these
movements
sometimes which are very strong and
powerful end up either getting crushed
or co-opted
without any real fundamental
transformation of the
society um and with sometimes fairly
marginal concessions
um coming from the ruling elite or the
traditional classes or whatever
um so when you take a look at those
cases and i think this is very much the
case now um
there are these large-scale protest
movements that have kind of like really
taken off
across southeast asia and also east asia
in the last several years
um thailand is one myanmar hong kong
taiwan right
and what's interesting about all of
these even though they're complex and
dynamic movements and
you know um we can't say that they all
necessarily stand for one thing but
there are a number of
folks in those protests that would
identify themselves as leftists or
socialists
in wanting a a fairer society
particularly in terms of income
redistribution
but they know that in order to get there
they they have to take away the
entrenched power of certain elites that
are above the law
um they need to have the rule of the law
they need to have
respect for constitutionalism they need
to have their basic political rights
respected first
because otherwise again not just as an
end in itself but as something that
will gradually lead to
the possibility of change um
a more social democratic or socialistic
change over time
because they've seen too often that the
alternative route
which is just trying to oppose um these
fairly entrenched authoritarian regimes
just kind of results
in cycles of repression um and and
disappointment
um and in the thai case that's been it's
been like that for the last 40 or 50
years
so hence this i think that
that type of struggle for for some of
the the background conditions
to put in other ways that we're we kind
of take for
we take advantage of or we take for
granted in the west are actually
necessary to fight for and i think
that's what people are fighting for
right now
in some of those locales so no i
absolutely agree with you and i think
this raises an interesting um well
theoretical and practical question when
you talk about issues of economic
justice
and its compatibility with the arguments
of some radical democrats
because one of the difficulties that
i've always had is that if you put
forward an
argument for a kind of economic justice
then it's hard to see how you can do
that without relying on some kind of
foundationless vision right that
this is the right kind of economic
distribution we should have or people
even more basically people should be
entitled to health care housing whatever
it happens to be
right and practically speaking i think
that these kinds of constructive
arguments
for economic justice resonate with
people quite a bit more than some of the
abstract arguments
made about agonism and one example that
i'll often point to is something like
lula's party uh the workers party in
brazil right
uh able to reduce poverty from twelve
percent to down to seven percent
uh through various different public
policies uh but you wouldn't be able to
have that
unless he was willing to stand up and
say this is what we should do
and this is what we're going to do right
because it's the right thing to do
right and can you think of any other
examples
whether in southeast asia or elsewhere
where these kinds of constructive
platforms organized around an idea of
economic justice
has actually mobilized a kind of
democratic uprising against powerful
elites that want to resist those kind of
changes
yeah um i mean i think there are
there there's a long there's a long
history of
social movements in that region that
have have tried to do
just that um and they've tried to put
forward a collective
platform of um transforming this society
in a way that would take away the power
of entrenched
elites um and entrenched in these in
this case don't just mean political but
also economic
um because we're talking about a region
where inequality is quite
quite stark um and crony capitalism is a
huge problem
um and maybe the only capitalism that
exists in the region is crony capitalism
so as a result everyone's favorite
capitalism
so as a result you know there have been
lots of popular mobilizations and in
places like the philippines
um which has a long history of popular
mobilization
in in a democratic way around those
issues um in indonesia
um in in thailand in some respect now
the issue in southeast asia
the one one thing that makes it quite
different than some latin american cases
is um the
the way in which those countries went
through their kind of post-independence
process and development process
was very much state-driven it was very
much elite driven
it did not allow for much much space for
organic civil society to develop
so civil society has been historically
weak unions have been historically weak
in that region
which has naturally taken a power taken
away power from
you know a classic classical left if you
will right
um and you also have very intense cold
war politics
where you know this was a region that of
course the united states was very
heavily engaged with
um you know the united states uh of
course with its engagement
in vietnam um tried to ally itself with
with countries like thailand with
singapore with others
because of the the fear of the communist
threat and this of course also led to
the disempowerment
of the left in a lot of ways and why you
you don't have such a strong social
democratic tradition
um in those regions um
and even even the radical tradition even
though it's there um
the radical leftist tradition i think is
is weaker than a place like latin
america
right where it has obviously a very very
strong and powerful history and then
plays
plays a large role um but nevertheless
it's there
and of course um platforms for economic
justice have often been on the agenda
i think in that region it's often taken
the form of populist politics
there's been a large number of populist
politicians that
even though not committed to the
transformation of this society have put
social justice
or economic justice on the agenda so in
the thai case
um someone like tuxen shinowat even
though he was like a multi-billionaire
media mogul who was
highly authoritarian and corrupt um he
was one of the first
mainstream type politicians to put that
on the agenda and he won election after
election and his proxies won election
after election
um but again what's interesting to go
back to the thai case and to go back to
my argument before right i think this is
one of the reasons why a lot of people
in that country are
um they're not just fighting for um
for something like socialism they
understand that without
without the rule of law without
political rights um
they will never be able to get there
that the parties that they vote for
are just going to be overthrown in coup
d'etats um
that the mobilizations that they they
put forward on the street in mass
numbers when things go wrong
are going to be harshly repressed by the
military
and hundreds die on the street um so you
know without without that type of
uh that transformation to something
that is more democratic in nature or
more liberal in nature if you will
that that other type of transformation
is really hard to envision so i think
those two things really come together so
it's an interesting region to explore
kind of the intersection
of the the demand for liberal democracy
and the demand for economic justice
um which sometimes in the west those two
things don't often go together because
you know liberal democracy is often
criticized as just kind of a
facade of the ruling classes right it's
just
the smoke screen behind oppression
whereas
i think in a place like that that's not
how it's seen um it's seen as a tool
at least or an instrument um
of a greater transformation later on
right
if if not something that's beneficial
and it's all right
oh absolutely i just wanted to add a
quick kind of follow-up uh a lot of my
friends at jacobin
um said they personally re-evaluated
things like the importance of liberal
democracy in the rule of law after
january 6
where a lot of people were being like
just pray to god that you know
uh the wall holds against this bulk
quark right so
i think that we can all um agree that
there are certain things about liberal
democracy that are certainly worth
preserving a peaceful transition of
power
from an authoritarian kleptocrat to a
modest kind of vanilla politician you
know being one of them
yeah totally yeah that's that's a good
way of putting it i was
one thing i would say about the january
6th thing is that
i mean i i received a lot of messages on
those days like everyone did
right from my family friends and
whatever um and
i i couldn't help but smirking a little
bit because again having
you know lived and work and study
southeast asia this is like
this is a monthly occurrence right this
is politics all the time
um so the reminder of you know the
importance of certain liberal democratic
features
um is is pretty it's much more obvious
right when you take a look at that
when you're kind of fixated on on the
west all the time
it can be easy to forget or easy to take
advantage of or take for granted
yeah totally i mean there really is this
temptation like among
western academics and this is actually
going to lead into my next question
which kind of brings us
a bit more back to the theoretical level
and maybe like it covers some of the
ground we we talked about earlier but i
guess
you know one thing that kind of
interests me about radical democracy and
maybe other
forms of radical politics and it also
speaks to
um you know what like what a lot of the
other stuff we do on this podcast too is
we you know we look at critical theory
and post-structuralist philosophy too
um and i think what you know
i think that like a lot of the times
there's a temptation in radical politics
to
to that is or there's a deep influence
it seems to me from post-structuralist
theory
and i guess like i had like my main
critique of combining post-structuralist
theory with with politics
is like it seems like the role that like
something like the emporia you know and
the undecidability of the social the
fact that everything is contingent
constructed
like i mean not everything but like you
know this is like the emphasis
in post structure and it seems to me
that that's sort of like what like low
and move
pick up on you know in their book you
know they pick up on these sort of like
post-structuralist
um insights and you know the i guess the
fact that the failure of traditional
marxism which
they like you know was premised on some
kind of like a thick ontology of like
the working class that they were like
well that's that doesn't make any
any sense anymore and i guess you know
it seems to me that these
post-structuralist insights are often
used by people with radical
uh political sensibilities to almost
over-invest it i think with like the
possibility of radical change it's like
because things are contingent
now anything's possible right or like it
makes it seem like it gives the
impression you know that that like
there's this open space where anything
anything can be done so therefore like
we should push against these structures
because we can transform it
almost into anything we want but i guess
you know
it seems to me that um that might be
missing that like this
space of openness is equally can
function
as like a barrier to change in a way and
i guess
i wonder whether you agree or or like um
have
some thoughts about that connection
between post-structuralism as like you
know
this openness and contingency um and
how it relates to politics yeah um
i mean it's it's a really great it's a
really great question
um and i think you're right a lot of the
there are a lot of radical thinkers that
draw in post-structuralism
for sure and in radical democratic
theory that's certainly true
um and maybe to link it back to my
earlier
earlier point or something else that i
said i think post-structuralism
um is is useful in helping
to recognize um
kind of unimagined possibilities or as
haunted might put it remainders or
exclusions that
other types of political theory are are
blind to
um and it does help kind of bring those
to light
right so if we go back to the cloud move
and maybe one could argue that this
could be done in a different way but in
hegemony and socialist strategy
one of their main critiques just like
you said was that um
by by moving away from
this emphasis on you know the working
class as kind of
the harbinger of the ultimate truth
right of the future to come
post-structure this thought and looking
at you know the various ways that power
operates in society and looking at the
various inequalities or inequities or
exclusions is able to actually widen the
horizon of
what needs to be transformed and i think
i think that's a fair point
um the the problem that i have and
maybe this is this goes back to the um
what we were talking about earlier it's
that point of
because of its post-foundationalism
because of its deconstructive nature
it becomes very difficult to put forward
any type of collective project some
would say even by default it becomes
impossible
um you can really only deconstruct and
critique
um and it becomes quite
quite difficult to in again in real
practice
to build something i mean theoretically
right i think it's quite quite easy
for for many post-structures thinkers to
say something like well we can have an
assemblage
of we have a constellation i think these
words are really common
in the literature right but what does
that look like
an ever more radical kind of democracy
right
that's that's that's interesting one
that's a good one um so yeah you know
this this type of language is used but
then when it comes to actual movement
building
right when it comes to people working
together on the ground and building
alliances
and having to put forward a collective
program
um not even necessarily for policy or
for change
even for just organizing an opposition
movement
um that that type of deconstruction
um i think does lead to
paralysis in a lot of ways and i'm not
just saying that theoretically i think
it has led
to paralysis i think it's one of the
reasons why
um particularly in the western world i
think and this isn't an original insight
or anything i think a lot of people have
said this
the reason why we're seeing this type of
politics where you have quite a lot of
anti-institutional and extra
institutional protest politics
is because this is the type of politics
that can be done in silos
right you can have this the multitude so
to speak
of you know different agents that really
are not connected they're all just kind
of against the same thing
in some way but to actually bring them
together
and have them coalesce into something
that could put forward a collective
project based on that
type of theory i think it's quite
limiting so i share your um
i share your critique in that sense
victor so i think i think it's useful
but again it's only it's only half
of what politics is about it's politics
it's not just about
again you know deconstructing old old
arrangements right
it's also about reconstructing or
reimagining
and building yeah actually
this will be my last question uh because
then i have to go pick up my key uh
but i think also one of the reasons why
post structuralists aren't necessarily
attracted to putting forward concrete
solutions
is in part because a lot of the
mundanity of everyday politics is pretty
bland from a theoretical perspective
uh and it's not interesting and the way
that kind of attracts the theorist
imagination
like an example that i typically give is
improving uh women's access to education
so in the province of kerala in central
india
there was a lot of concern about how it
is that parents could be encouraged to
send their girls to school
right uh and originally the idea was
we'll offer them a monetary stipend to
send their girls to school
rather than sending them to the factory
uh and it didn't work because the system
was so corrupt
that people just took the money and they
sent their girls to factories
so what the state decided to do instead
is offer a meal to these girls at the
school
about 600 calories but you had to send
them there in order to get it
right and parents consequently sent more
of their kids to school
uh this is a pretty practical thing
right
but it's not particularly theoretically
interesting but it had a massive
influence
on women's education in the state and
hundreds of thousands of girls enrolled
who wouldn't have been enrolled
otherwise
right uh and these are the kinds of
imaginative and kind of constructive
projects
that i think the left needs to mobilize
around
uh because it's you can point to it as a
kind of concrete way
that institutions responded to
inequality and did something that
tangibly made people's lives better
right
very very marginalized peoples so i'm
wondering if
you had you know a magic wand right
uh and you could just wave it over uh
radicals today
what kind of concrete proposals would
you want them to adopt
that's uh that's a really good question
no one's ever given me the magic wand
well that's it you now have the power to
enact meaningful change and say
this way we march uh and no other i
think
i think what i would say in in terms of
the
key proposals and this is something that
has obviously been been spoken
quite a lot about and i i think it
doesn't
um it doesn't require a lot of reading
today you just have to you know look at
the
social media or the news um over the
course of a week to figure this out
we we have a highly
divided fragmented societies
um i think even um the
the degree of fragmentation uh has
increased
or at least has been amplified in volume
in terms of what i'm hearing and seen
since i wrote the dissertation um and
i i think it might sound kind of uh
quite straightforward
matt but it's it's really about again
finding common ground
between people that that might have
different issues might have different
concerns
but rallying around those common demands
so in the case of kerala right that that
might be something
like um education for girls right
it might be something substantive like
pushing for um
for meals at school right um or it could
be something like
you know fairer tuition fees or a living
wage
or certain reforms of institutions that
will allow for more
uh more input from ordinary people right
um things that we we hear
from i think a variety of different
opponents to how things are working
right now um
but i think because of the fragmentation
that we see we
we don't see a real a real push
for for commonality um because i think
it's quite and maybe part of this is
because of the influence of
post-structuralist thought and there are
other reasons too
there's there's a tendency to focus on
differences right
um and there's a tendency to focus on
what uh
what people don't share um as opposed to
what people do share
and i mean i can see how even what i'm
saying right now can
can be criticizing to be considered
problematic because it's it's suggesting
a type of homogeneity
um potentially uh not recognizing
the forms of oppression that exists or
hide behind commonality
etc right that would be a pretty
uncharitable interpretation of what
you're saying but yeah
i could see it but i could see it coming
um if somebody really wanted to take
issue with what you're saying i
absolutely agree
so i it's i think it's just it's finding
the common denominators again
right and and this is actually where i
think you know some of radical
democratic thought
is is still quite useful um but going
back to the clown move
um one aspect i really like about the
work even though i'm not
uh i'm not very sold on that agonistic
part and
the possibility of the agonistic part is
um the idea of
equivalential chains right and it's it's
more of a clause idea with a chain of
equivalence right
and what is the chain of equivalence
well it's it's when people do have when
people do have
common demands they do have some degree
of commonality that can be stitched
together regardless of that difference
right um so and i think in real world
politics today
uh maybe particularly in the western
world we've just got a lot less emphasis
on those commonalities
between you know the various groups that
that all have issues with
the different aspects of this system
right so that i think that's what i
would
do with the wand great uh that's that's
great you know i
i think that's probably a good place to
to stop you know i feel like i've been
i've asked all my questions and you know
i gotta say it was uh it was such a
pleasure and it's nice you know i
discovered your book too in this context
where
i think i kind of had these like
feelings of dissatisfaction and then it
was just like very
very surreal to find a book that just
like captured what i was feeling but
then like gave me the
the sort of like at least a direction to
go in because i you know i had those
feelings so you know i thank you for
writing the book and yeah it worked out
really well for well i'm happy
i'm happy that it was uh it was helpful
um it was a lot of fun writing it doing
the case studies was a lot of fun and
it was really revealing for me too it
was really one of those projects where i
uh i think like you know good research
should be
the hypotheses and the ideas that i had
the beginning were not the same as when
i finished and i became a lot more um
a lot more suspicious of a radical
democratic thought
even though i'm still sympathetic to to
quite a bit of it
there there's quite a lot more of it
that i
i actually see is maybe even holding
holding us back
um from you know
a more just world and more just
societies or
or even real political engagement right
which is something that they're big on
and this goes back to the comments that
matt made about you know political
engagement being a matter of
construction and building um and
focusing on that
so i'm curious what were your like
initial hypotheses did you did you have
like a much more initial optimistic
uh belief about what the sort of
outcomes you'd find
it was it was more it was more
optimistic
um i i think i was
planning or maybe even hoping in some
ways to find
that these um
these kind of spirit of the moment
movements right that took off
and really disrupted the status quo
in ways that had you know not previously
been imagined
um that they were going to be actually
more important than they ended up being
right and i think like i said one thing
that i realized is that
it it wasn't that romantic moment of
stepping out as i put it in the book
right it wasn't the moment of taking to
the streets that actually made the
difference in terms of how
that particular political situation
transpired or unfolded
it was it was the kind of larger context
um those bigger struggles that that you
know initial spark was really only a
part of
so i think that that's kind of um what
maybe the biggest lesson i learned from
it right is that i
i think maybe i also bought into some of
the romanticism right
of pure politics of that that moment of
interruption or disruption which is
attractive right because it is
there's something to it about people uh
working together um outside of their
normal spaces
as equals um you know
trying to reimagine something different
um but
yeah as i found out i think that was
only a starting place for all of these
movements
yeah for sure well the book is a radical
democracy in its limits uh
david matajosevich thanks so much for
coming on and uh yeah we'll put a link
to the book
uh in the description of course these
academic books tend to be pretty
expensive but i can say that i picked
mine up i think it was like a christmas
sale
and it was like 60 off so sometimes just
watch out for those sales because
palgrave does have some really really
great stuff and i actually found your
book
fine enough because i was just browsing
the sale
so like i don't even like so i didn't
even find it from google scholar i was
just i was like oh my god i'm
researching radical democracy here's a
book called radical democracy and its
limits and i
read the description read the review and
i was like okay well perfect i'm going
to pick it up
so yeah listeners maybe that'll come
around again so this sales
oh it's always good to keep an eye on
those cells because you're right um it
is
it is an expensive one um as academic
books are and i also got a lot of flack
for that people thought it was my fault
yeah matt's in the same boat matt matt's
got some books with pal grave too and he
runs into the same thing yeah and
i sat there and it was just like why the
[ __ ] is your book 150 and you're arguing
for like
liberal socialism or whatever i'm like
hey man believe me if i were in your
shoes i wouldn't buy it either so
yeah that's that's that's what i that's
what i suggest too so
um i'm always happy when people read the
book but i don't necessarily want to uh
suggest that you go and buy it
cool well great note to end on thanks so
much both and it was great
thanks a lot
[Music]
you